more london systems
from the world champion very often
when push comes to shove magnus resorts
to the london system
and we get this position again where
irony already tried knight to six knight
a5 which didn't work so well this time
he goes for bishop c6
maybe wants to go knight bd7
knight e2 plate
carlson just slowly building on the king
side knight g3 now g5 is probably a
threat
since knight 1985 it's no longer
possible
and aronia allows g5 arguing that g5
weakens in my position
he's then in time to re-shuffle his
knight i know
still daring i would think magnus
probably doesn't go g5
so his style to weaken the structure he
goes queen g1
not sure what that's about frankly
mayweather's knight b3 is a threat
a4 nice move stopping knight b3
queen b1 not sure
this is the way queen b3 to d1 and then
to b1
carson has faith in the solidity of his
structure
bishop to b5 looks like this time around
aronia is solving his opening problems
in this london system
again we're rid of the light squared
bishops
should be fine carlson continues to gain
space on this side of the board
looked like magnus was just cruising but
now
all of a sudden things got
a lot more tense
e3 plate
i could still go b4 but i guess you
don't want to cd i'm curious if it's
going to go e d
leading to his favorite car spot
structure but this position cd
might be more circumspect
um yeah he goes cd just keeping his
construction in the center
the king can probably sit here
i actually like white's position king
two rook c1
he goes knight b6 let's put the knight
on c4
nice maneuvering by dr liver and aromian
as well
j7 g5 i'm reading that yesterday all the
lines were covered
yeah i'm sorry it's i guess choice one
has to make
for me in a blitz game where the moves
are coming in so quickly
i always find it more confusing or just
my
personal taste if one
does too many lines then again
i have been accused of doing too many
lines plenty in my life
so maybe else a reason
why i'm trying to keep it closer to the
position of the board
it's not enough lines for you i
understand and i would like to apologize
knight to c4 planning some exchanges
i don't know if you go b4 here
somewhat ugly
but unclear to me what else you do
knight b3 looks wrong
just leaving this pawn there you don't
want to take
because of the bc
black structure improves significantly
so i'm very curious how magnus
will handle this maybe yeah yeah i swear
i was going to say maybe he's fine along
the exchange
playing the end game with b3
that allows it takes a3 as well
tens position
this is the final chat first of four and
a half wins
so magnus carson was up three and a half
half
it looked like he was just
sailing to victory
i live in aronia just won two games in a
row
it's back in business magnus could still
wrap it up
by winning this one
and but
still a lot of work goes e4
goes for a change of structure here
cheers
after d e i guess both make some sense
he wants to take with the pawn go for
the pawn center
or go knight takes e4
not sure
there's your answer he does wanna take
with the pawn
keep the structure intact but now this
will create
trying to target the knight feels like
black is active enough to hold the
balance white is the slightly better
structure
but it does not look like it should be
enough
82 fishing for new squares
e5 nice move allows allows a protected
passport with d5
but greatly restricts this knight i
don't think yeah megan's not gonna go t5
with this horsey sitting here
i have a feeling he also can sense his
touch he's gone a little bit which is
normal he was dominating but then you
lose two blitz is often also a bit of a
game of runs
now of course level has more confidence
so magnus is trying to
stop that momentum play it safe here
it's end game now
yeah i guess is equal
95 king d2
knight f5 exchanging the bishops
to me it looks like magnus made a
business decision he's going for a draw
here but
just as i say it he does continue the
game
address pressure so as usual i'm wrong
it looked like he was at the very least
try to
keep it simple
knight d7 engine bar going a little nuts
here
once in a while he's saying now white
can win
but
very hard for puny humans to understand
what's going on here
this knight is headed towards c4
magnus tries a new maneuver
whenever this knight c5 is played
computer goes nuts with
i don't know taking on f6
didn't happen white is still better
because these pawns
are more vulnerable than the white pawns
will magnus manage to squeeze this out
knight c4
pawn falls
is this the last game knight c6
the a pawn is going to run as well
knight takes b3
knight takes b4
and whoa a5 draw perpetual
oh magnus upset or he's laughing
but yeah he allowed the perpetual whoa
the match continues